[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live laura cognito
here i love podcastinggaming.net
in the realm of facts east who is this
amazing gentleman that is lord in the
round i'm gabriel i'm from massive work
studio and i'm with this game over here
dolman massive work dolmen this is one
of the games that we've had our eye on
so let's get right to it and actually
for people who are unfamiliar with
goldman what type of games though okay
so dolmen is a souls-like game with a
lot of inspirations and dark souls
bloodborne but also inspirations in some
games that are not usually matched with
so like example a mass effect also that
space so a lot of lovecraft also in it
so you get a little bit of horror
in space so
that's a sci-fi game and it's a hard
game all right cool let's get right into
it we got a lot out of the gameplay you
gotta check this thing out dolmen
awesome looking really cool so right now
we're seeing the different um loadouts
so the big difference in domain over
here is that we have a mixed combat we
have ranged at combat and also melee
combat so in here we have three loadouts
one more focus on melee gameplay one
more focuses on a mix of gameplay you
want more focuses on range of the
gameplay so they arrange the gameplay
it's all about guns nice rifles pistols
and things like that that's that's the
real thing here over here i love the
architecture on the suits thank you very
cool some of them are really a little
more humanish some of them are more
robotic and we have some some suits that
have a little more uh
creature side of things so for example
that shield yes it is made from pieces
of bodies of awful some of them animals
oh that's awesome yes that's awesome
right now i'm still drinking a little
bit of customization exactly so that is
color customization if you press dpad up
you can check it out some colors that
you can put either on your full armor or
each piece individually yeah so does
that what does that mean that you can
mix and match the armors you can have
some humanist armors and also some
creatures like armors all of them at the
moment nicely i like that that is very
underrated feature especially
customization being able to mix and
match i'm about to style
attic that's disgusting keep going
keep going
it looks really good it worse
this is where we go
oh look that's the joker you're the
stylist
virginia okay
so now here's a little bit of story in
the game
so you're this mercenary you have been
hired to retrieve these domain crystals
from this planet called reference prime
but it happens that this planet of this
planet is suffering from an
intergalactic invasion so they're
releasing creatures inside this planet
and also they're really invaded and is
slaughtering everybody you see somebody
that
all over the place
so people are starting to get jumped on
okay okay one thing i'm gonna notice off
the top i love the the cinematic
storytelling you know very immersive
graphic fidelity looks very high thank
you well what engine are we using is
this unreal yeah that's a real engine
four
okay yeah that's unreal engine 4 and
differently from other souls like games
uh we're more into telling the story a
little bit more directly so we have a
lot of cinematics a lot of cutscenes and
also a lot of
data pads and lore spread around the
road literally for you to interact and
and and hear the story a little so
basically we get a lot of lore bits and
i'm a huge fan of this this is the style
of storytelling i i call it hashtag just
one which is the cinematic pool of the
shoulder storytelling yeah and i love it
because it really immerses you in the
world yeah and not coupled with this
graphic fidelity it's really looking
impressive for the visuals awesome thank
you yeah and we are using uh some
next-gen features so we have do have ray
tracing for those ones that they like
okay yeah and ray tracy on the ps5 as
well and also on xbox series awesome
this looks good let's go at it he's
moving around he's got a sword and
shield you got the gun i love the
over-the-shoulder mass effect vibe yeah
you know sci-fi feel and one thing that
you can see over here is that you also
have those
kind of dots on top of the weapons
that's your elements dominant messes a
lot with the elements of the weapon so
for example over here he's now have a
fire arrangement weapon and they
immediately ranked the weapon so they
mix and match okay uh you can fire in
your enemy and apply fire so he will
have less defense and when attacking
with the fire weapon he'll give you
extra damage over here the the heavy
shot gives you these uh spins that good
has a lot of more uh
bullets before shooting at the same time
nice nice so right now again the premise
is kind of looking for these dolmen
crystals he's in this world and again
they've got i'm seeing the dark side
for energy mode
nice
now i see this blue meter over the
enemies can you explain what that is yes
so that is the effect being applied
right now he's frozen so it's really
easier for for for him to to fight
against him right you're out of energy
you should use a battery by pressing
d-pad down
yeah he's suffering
yeah right
if he grabs you till the end he grows
bigger
faster and stronger later literally wow
now from a dying mechanic is it one of
those situations like a dark souls no
you have items and if you lose them can
you get them back what what's the whole
is there any penalty for the doctor yes
there is so on top over here you have
this your sparks and also your domain
fragments so whenever you die you lose
your spikes which is similar to some
kind of sauce okay uh and you have to
get your body back to recover those toes
gotcha so almost like the rules in a
alden ring exactly okay exactly and the
domain fragments are the ones that are
used for
uh respawning bosses because you can
respawn bosses in order to
farm and grind the materials for of them
because you can craft unique weapons
with their materials
and also for multiplayer so we do
support multiplayer on the bosses so up
to four players you can get help from
your friends to defeat that hard boss
that you're having what can you offer
for bosses specifically yes
up to four
up to four players wow that is pretty
impressive
very impressive so we're moving along i
love that dash mechanic that had yes and
did you have also dash attacks backstep
attacks running attacks all of those
types of guys so the advantage okay of
the range i would say
obviously our distance is safe but is it
because of the batteries that are
limited that you could that you can't
stay in that kind of a long let's say i
wanted to stay in a long range style
yeah you can you can okay you can
but you really have to be more careful
because the energy that you see over
there yeah you see that it's a little
bit consumed so you you'll not be able
to shoot that much so we have to use
your batteries in order to recover the
energy but that energy is the one that
is used for healing so healing is
instantaneously but consuming the
batteries takes time so you need to
really have that balance between hey do
i heal or do i keep shooting that's an
interesting dynamic so it's pretty much
like an offense defense in a way because
like you said you make that tough choice
hey i want to have more energy to
consume to use for range weapons but at
the expense of low health if you're
alone exactly and you may need to stay
alive exactly interesting mechanic very
cool yeah for example right now he
doesn't have any energy so he wasn't
able to too soon
okay yeah if you wanted a recommendation
i would use the other wrenching weapon
because you're using a fire melee weapon
so how does he switch attack how do you
switch
that up yeah it has some really nice
shots that's the heavy shot
and that's the really shot so you apply
the fire right now that's the bar that's
over there uh so now he has lesser
defense
which may be helpful if you hit
something
don't joke
nice cool can we get some consuming
energy
that may need some energy he needs some
energy he needs to heal he needs to heal
how does he heal you press x and you can
heal yeah you see that the bar got it
now with the effects i see like i said
fire snow it's fire ice and acid and
acid yes now is there any
obviously they're going to be enemies
that'll be more susceptible to certain
things yes right is there any advantage
of doing combinations or can you combine
or kind of one at a time focus these
different elements more enemies
weaknesses there are differences but
some animals
some enemies as you said has some more
weakness and some strength okay so for
example some of them can't be frozen for
example but
every element has its advantage so
the ice slows the enemies down so it
gets easier for you to dodge and grab
the timing of the enemy and stuff like
that uh while the acid uh
sorry the fire
kisses the defense and the acid does
both but a little bit less but a little
less okay cool
absolutely bold so
you have this all these different play
styles that you whatever you wish is the
best for you it's the one that you can
go for
so that is some piece of our information
that you can see so he's probably
hearing uh a little voice on on if
you're excited about this yeah so we
have voice in portuguese because we're
from brazil and also voice in english
nice uh the game is also translated for
six uh almost 16 languages when i'm
mistaken it's 12 volts 16. yeah now let
me ask you this from the development
standpoint because i'll be honest it
looks extremely polished right now thank
you so much my question is like how long
has our doorman been in development okay
it has been in development since 2017.
so it's been a long journey uh right now
we have the publisher the prime matter
but before we were alone and we even
made a kickstarter it got successful and
now we were able to to deliver this this
game right now because we're going to
see the fruits a lot of time a lot of
time and it's finally coming out okay
we're going to get to that we're going
to get to that the previous shot is
definitely about that what is going on
with this guy right here okay
this guy he's like an
it builds
so what you're using right now is not
really effective so every time that you
shoot at him he deflected so you neither
either go around him or you get the
right timing and yeah that's what he's
doing right now hey and now you should
be able to attack him
yeah he's tough yeah he's really tough
he's really tired you need to really use
the heavy attacks and exploit the other
weapon that you have if you don't lock
on and you shoot at his feet it will be
better so the other weapon okay yeah see
if you can see there you go yeah and now
turn off the lock on
and you can manually aim
and shoot the right heavy weapon at his
foot
yeah a little bit below a little bit
below
it's a little bit
less on the foot so he gets jumped into
that damage gotcha now as far as like
as you progress in the world and stuff
like that um is it is it like hub based
is there like a grander world yes or is
it level based yeah it's a little bit
more leaner path line but it has a lot
of different areas with different
scenarios so there's more open scenarios
and there's more close scenarios like
these ones
in here is 10 plus hours in the game
that's why some enemies are really
difficult so we're training okay yeah
you're not in the beginning of the game
you have already killed six bosses he's
a pro already
this bar as long as you don't overuse it
it will start recharging yes exactly so
that's that's the benefit from from
range of the weapons the range of the
weapons they they can shoot and they
they recharge it but the heavy shot for
example because some of the abilities
are really powerful so they consume it
so it's pretty much like on bloodworm or
if you don't hit it too many times his
health starts to generate yes exactly
uh
the same goes for the energy mode the
energy mode we use just your reactor so
when you press y uh you enter into
energy mode and then you can apply the
effect of the record that you use that
did
drop down is no joke you got energy for
it
nice nice so for example can you try
pressing y further energy mode so right
now you're in good with the eyes every
time that you attack for example do an
attack
using a light wave of
ice and also you use energy instead of
stamina so let's say that you're almost
killing that boss right and
you go out of stamina and that's last
hit
turn on energy mode give that last hit
and then it's over nice nice now is
there
also
any finishing mechanics or not really
that's just a difference not really
yeah so
unfortunately we don't have those
finished mechanics we do have only the
block and parry gotcha so we do have a
pair you do have a prairie okay but not
a repose on the
oh good all good loving this right now
one thing i really enjoy too
as a person who's a mass effect fan when
he goes into the over the shoulder
it takes me back
i can tell you clearly that the dev team
is clearly inspired yeah about that
because
i love that
we literally
played a lot of different games in order
to get some references it also gets
inspirations yes right over there if you
shoot it i didn't
man yeah take that shield dude awesome
bro you know you see that you know
you're 12 years old you guys are are you
guys supposed to be oh yeah
yeah so checking that out right now got
him got him
what was that dolphin the dominant
fragment is the one that is used for
multiplayer or also for re for
respawning with bosses so that's your
body right there
timeline restart
so every time that you die a new
timeline uh is starts and the other one
is erased and you restart the timeline
so does the story revolve around some
form of time mechanic and why it's
timeline uh it's because of the domain
fragments the domain fragments messes
with timelines so uh the thing that you
are playing is a timeline and every time
that you die
it is like you're living a different
timeline gotcha yeah
let me explain a little bit to the
viewers
what makes this unique than some of the
other solar flight games i've played is
this bar is pretty much dictating what
range and health you can do so for
instance like
if i
if i if i am fighting someone that i
need to be a
distance away from but i'm still low on
health yeah i'm gonna have to heal and
and real quick i know we could wrap it
up but as far as like the uh the boss uh
boss fights now i'm assuming that we're
gonna have some in this game we have
nine boss fights and one of them is a
double so there's two enemies at that
boss fight you can get to the boss fight
if you rush it in uh going to the other
path let's see if we can rush into that
other pair yeah go go that way let's
just see what the ball yeah just run
yeah just around because there will be
enemies all over the place
don't stop don't start this move round
just run
and then you go to your left and enter
that room okay let's go nice
and don't look back man a little bit
don't stop
yeah they're coming you just don't know
it but if you had your headphones you
you'd be hearing yes all right let's go
just look just get a glimpse back oh
yeah
after you go to the middle of this room
you are safe yeah and it goes through
that door
which you know which one here right here
yeah now they stopped all right so so
that's the terminal that where you can
respawn bosses also call for help all
right and now it's the boss just out of
curiosity
you
you have implemented some kind of
feature to help far more additional
resources because like yes so that's the
the response
usually developers at this type of game
they're real greedy on the boss fights
they're like you only get that one right
no you want a resource you get them as
much as you want now when you do you get
more resources for the first time you
beat them than the rest or is it just
the same throughout the first time you
get a little bit more resources on the
second ones and the other ones you get
only the special materials that they get
and also some sparks all right let's go
any type of material that you can farm
off these people too yes so it's one
exactly
so there's
a lot of
a lot of weapons
yeah one shot
so that's a she by the way okay she's dr
loboja she messed it around with
dominant fragments and also some
creatures she made some tests and
backfired
yeah give me a bit give me a little
resident evil tyrant
yeah
she hits hard
she hits really
really hard ready for that smoke
let's go
you're diamond
how are you putting on
there we go there we go nice nice that's
something really nice that's a nice damn
she's really susceptible to eyes also to
range damage but you see she punishes
you
see
whoa
oh stop she's coming
getting real
nice
yeah
let's go it's two hits if she if she
hits you twice and he has a second phase
it's a baby
let's go watch your back
nice let's get that shot on there you go
yeah he's a good player he's a good
player this is a difficult game
yeah
and the real thing over here is abusing
those pillars and letting her go rushing
good gosh let's go
oh
it's pretty close he was so close it was
so close it was one of the closest nice
man
good job dolmen got it before we got
close uh
i i
but the good thing is you balance it
that the uh the enemies are a little
slower too yeah
i noticed that it was easier to dodge
that boss because i could forget
so as you were saying
dolmen been in development for a while
getting close now where are we in terms
of release i know we talked about
platforms with wearing in terms of
release we're really close so it's
coming out on 20th of may right now
right around the corner yes
ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series and
steam yeah we got you covered listen man
absolutely fantastic love the use of
unreal unreal engine it looks phenomenal
unique gameplay mechanic a lot of
defense offense customization yes fights
you guys got a lot of things covered and
the cooperative aspect of bringing in
people to help i love that kind of
sci-fi kind of aesthetic
dolmen y'all want to watch in the realm
the lords will keep their eye on this an
absolute pleasure thank you the pleasure
is all my man massive work putting in
massive work
shout out to brazil
no doubt i a little podcast
thanksgiving.net
[Music]
you